Was dann geht, da eigentlich
ist schon zu den eigentlich
wichtigsten Themen von heute,
zu den Funktionen über.
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen nachdenkt,
wir haben hier schon ein paar Funktionen
durchgemacht, zum Beispiel
das LEN, wenn ihr euch
daran erinnert.
Was macht das LEN?
Also da haben wir eine Liste
rein zum Beispiel.
Das LEN,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
das ist,
das kommt
vom englischen Wort
LENGF.
Das ist da,
das ist praktisch Länge
bedeutet.
Wir wollen praktisch die Länge
von unserer Liste haben,
und die ist da 1, 2, 3.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier eine 3 raus.
Und das hier
ist so eine Funktion.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier
diese Liste als Input
und dann bekommen
ein Output, das wäre dann unser 3.
Praktisch.
Schaut dann so aus.
Wir haben dann praktisch dieses LEN Keyword,
macht dann im Hintergrund
irgendwas.
Was praktisch
dann zu diesem 3
führt.
Genau,
und da haben wir dann diesen Output.
Normalerweise, dieser Output wird mit diesem
Return Keyword zurückgegeben.
Nicht jede Funktion
muss dieses Return haben.
Dann haben wir eine Funktion
ohne Rückgabewert.
Kann zum Beispiel auch einfach nur
einen Konsolen-Output machen, also mit
Print.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier die
Parameter in ein
Pfeilspeichern
oder in andere
Variablespeichern.
Zum Beispiel
Print ist ja auch so ein Statement,
als eine Funktion.
Gehen wir das mal anhand von diesem
Beispiel hier durch.
Das heißt, wir haben hier Print,
dieses Attest.
Das heißt, wir haben hier 4 Parameter.
Die Funktion ist Print.
Das hier.
Und ausgegeben
wird praktisch dann in der Konsole
dieses Attest.
Ebenes gleich mit LEN zum Beispiel.
Da haben wir auch hier in diesem Fall
unser Argument,
was in diesem Fall praktisch diese Liste ist.
Und dann bekommen wir diesen Rückgabewert.
Das ist ein bisschen return
Value.
In diesem Fall.
Und wenn wir so eine Funktion selber definieren,
dann schaut das ungefähr so aus.
Also, was fällt
da auf? Einerseits dieses Def.
Das Def
kommt von Define.
Define Funktion.
Also, das solltet ihr auf jeden Fall merken.
Dann unseren Funktionsnamen.
Wie ihr seht, haben wir da
alles kleinpustamen.
Und
wenn es ein längerer Funktionsnamen
ist und mehrere Wörter beinhaltet,
dann könnt ihr das mit diesem
Anderscore hier trennen.
Das kann natürlich auch einfach Def Test heißen.
Also, wie ihr wollt.
Und dann haben wir diese,
hier haben wir einen Parameter.
Also, es ist eine Variable, die wir dann
hier definieren.
Und die können wir dann hier verwenden.
Aber nur in
praktisch in diesem Funktionsblock.
Wie ihr seht, haben wir hier wieder eine Einrückung.
Und dann können wir da mit
unserem Format String
diesen Parameter ausgeben.
In diesem Fall würde
das einfach
U-Past 13 to this Funktion.
Und wie ihr hier seht,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert
an die Feedbackerfrage,
da haben wir gehabt, dass praktisch
nichts ausgegeben wird.
Und das liegt daran, dass wir das nicht gemacht haben.
Wir haben praktisch diese Funktion aufgerufen
in unserem Code.
Wichtig, das ist dann nicht
im Funktionsblock, sondern
irgendwo anders.
Also, das muss dann mindestens auf derselben
Ebene sein, wie die Definition
der Funktion.
Kann aber auch dann
trotzdem noch weiter drin sein.
Wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel
im Funktionsblock drin ist,
dann nennt man das eine rekursive Funktion.
Das heißt, die ruft sich immer selber auf.
Das ist auch so eine Art Endloschleife.
Genau.
So eine Funktion ist praktisch
einfach so eine Art benannter Codeblock.
Also, sagen wir mal, ich hab 100 Zeigen Code.
Und möchte den
wiederverwenden können,
wenn ich diesen Codeblock mit dieser Define
Function
und dann kann ich eben diese Function
einfach immer wieder aufrufen
und das wird mir in dieser 100 Zeigen
Code einfach wieder aufrufen.
Wichtige Funktionen,
die wir ja schon kennengelernt haben,
ist dieses LAN, das Print und das Input
und definiert es eben mit diesem
Def, Name der Funktion
und dann eine Parameterliste.
Das werden wir dann genau
jetzt dann gleich genau durchmachen
und wichtig ist eben, der Codeblock
ist wie beim IF oder bei einer Vorschleife
oder einer Weisschleife
eingerückt, also wieder unsere vier Leerzeigen.
Und dann ganz zum Schluss,
falls wir jetzt
in diesem Codeblock was generieren,
dann können wir diesen Wert
natürlich dann auch wieder
an unseren äußeren Codeblock zurückgeben
und das machen wir mit Return.
Dazu aber auch gleich mehr.
Also so einfache Funktionen,
also Beispiele sind
zum Beispiel hier,
hier haben wir
die erste Funktion, die ist die
TestSimple,
wie ihr seht, hat die kein Parameter definiert,
das geht natürlich auch,
also die muss kein Parameter haben
und dann rufen wir die auf
und das heißt,
hier passiert ja nichts,
hier passiert ja auch nichts,
dann wird hier
diese Funktion aufgerufen,
das heißt, ihr bekommt hier dann
dieses Print Statement
mit High Everyone,
das wird dann in die Konsole ausgegeben
und dann kommt hier zum nächsten
Funktionsaufruf,
da springt dann hier wieder rein,
hier übergeben wir einen Parameter,
String Hello,
da wird dann hier mit dieser Print Funktion
in die Konsole aufgerufen
und dann springen wir wieder zurück
und gehen hier weiter.
Wir werden das dann auch gleich
haustesten, noch
kurz zur Definition,
es gibt nämlich
zwei Art, es gibt Funktionen
und es gibt Methoden,
Methoden, zum Beispiel
haben wir das hier,
das hier,
das hier, zum Beispiel auch das Strip,
woran erkennt man eine Methode,
da haben wir nämlich
unsere Variable,
Punkt
und dann
unsere Methode,
und was Methoden so
anders zu Funktionen macht,
ist,
die geht her und schaut sich an,
was da drin ist
und praktisch
führt ihren
Funktionscode anhand
von dem Wert dieser Variable aus,
also wenn da jetzt eben
sagen wir mal,
so was,
dann kann man das eigentlich
so interpretieren,
das heißt,
wenn man das jetzt in eine Funktion
umschreiben würde,
wäre das dann so
und wir müssen das eben nicht machen,
wir können das eben so machen.
Und das ist eigentlich der Riesenunterschied
zu den normalen Funktionen,
wie ihr euch vielleicht
erinnern könnt, Funktionen
definieren wir
mit dem Dev Keyword
und Methoden sind meistens
schon definiert,
in diesen Kursen
machen wir eigentlich nichts mehr Klassen durch,
ja, will ich da auch nichts mehr dazu sagen,
aber eigentlich wichtig ist einfach,
das gehört dann zum Objekt.
Also da hat, ja, das ist dann ein bisschen komplizierter,
da könnt ihr euch dann das eigentlich
cyber recherchieren, falls ihr das genau rissen wollt,
aber eigentlich wichtig ist nur,
dass praktisch normale Funktionen mit dem Dev Keyword
definiert worden sind
und Methoden, also
nennen wir, wenn sie so was sind,
also mit diesem Punkt.
Dann kommen wir zu den
Return Values.
Ich müsste das jetzt so verstellen,
ich habe jetzt eine Funktion
und die berechnet mir jetzt was.
Sag mal, die macht 1 plus 2
und ich will diesen Wert aber
zurück haben,
dann muss ich das mit Return machen,
praktisch
ich
returniere diesen Wert
und dann gehen wir
praktisch,
kehren wir zurück zum Hauptprogramm,
das heißt dort, wo der Funktion
die Funktion aufgerufen wurde,
also sagen wir zum Beispiel,
wir haben ja x ist gleich 0,
dann haben wir,
rufen wir unsere Funktion auf
mit
x drin
okay, das sollte man vielleicht
y dazuschreiben.
Dann macht die intern irgendwas
Return diesen neuen Wert
und dann speichern wir uns dann in dieser Variable y.
Praktisch, die springt dann dort
zu hin, wo
diese Funktion definiert worden ist
und
dann springt sie eigentlich
wieder hier zurück
und dann
wird das
nächste hier ausgeführt.
Das heißt, wir können da bis
dem Kot herum springen
aber wir kommen dann eigentlich immer wieder
als das sobald das aufgerufen wird,
wird das abgearbeitet
und dann gehen wir eigentlich zum nächsten
genau das können wir zum Beispiel
sagen wir, wir haben hier dieses
Beispiel hier
diese Funktion format name
die bekommt 2
Parameter übergeben
first and last
dann kombiniert sie diese Parameter
hier mit einem Format string
in einen einzelnen string
dann rufen wir auf diesen string
also die umspeichern das hier in dieses
fullname Variable
und dann machen wir da noch fullname.title
und dann returner
diesen Wert, das heißt
was wenn wir hier in namet drinstehen haben
gehen wir mal das kurz durch
praktisch Arnold Schwarzenegger sind unsere Parameter
das heißt hier haben wir dann Arnold
und Schwarzenegger drinstehen
dann kombinieren wir das zu einem
einzelnen string
dann rufen wir
Deidlauf
das wandelt dann
diesen string hier mit
klein und großbruchstaben
in einen
schönen formatierten string
den returnen wir dann
und dann haben wir hier in name
jetzt Arnold Schwarzenegger drinstehen
da kann man natürlich auch
nicht nur strings oder einzelne integers
so was zurückgeben, da kann man auch
komplizierte Sachen zurückgeben
man kann listen, man kann
sets, man kann dictionaries
man kann alles mögliche zurückgeben
man kann auch mehrere mit beistrich
getrennt Variablen so zurückgeben
was man das haben möchte
das wird vom Beifen eigentlich
intern immer als duppel behandelt
das können wir auch kurz zeigen
hier habe ich einfach 3
das kann man sich vorstellen
sind wie 3 einzelne
Werte hier
und wenn wir da jetzt
cool aufrufen
sonst
seht ihr, bekommen wir das
als duppel zurück
wenn ich da zum Beispiel noch x definiere
kann ich das auch noch zurückgeben
und dann wird
praktisch dieser Wert von x
returniert
kann da auch noch
was komplizierter das machen
da habe ich da
x als dictionary
das kann ich auch noch
was komplizierter das machen
da habe ich da
x als dictionary definiert
das kann ich auch zurückgeben
wenn ich nur x haben will
geht das auch
da wird es aber nicht ein duppel umgewandelt
weil wir ja keine beistrische haben
und wir kommen wir praktisch nur
den Wert von x zurück
also return
gibt es praktisch
den Wert
der definierten Variablen hier
zurück
ist da zu fragen
dann kommen wir zu den Argumenten
also dieses Parameter
ich habe das jetzt mal hier
in rot und blau markiert
weil da gibt es 2 verschiedene
Arten wie ihr das machen könnt
da gibt es einmal
die Positional Arguments
die sind praktisch definiert
durch die Position
also hier
first
ist praktisch schon
an der 1. Position
das heißt wenn wir hier
einen Wert an der 1. Position
reinschreiben
dann wird das automatisch
in die 1. Position
also in dem Parameter
der an der 1. Position ist
reingeschrieben
wäre die z.B. an der 2. Position
dann würde es in
das zweite Argument reinschreiben
wir können das Ganze
aber auch mit Keywords machen
das heißt wir haben ja hier
diesen Funktionsparameter
praktisch definiert
der heißt der Last
den gibt es sonst nichts
also der ist hier wirklich
das 1. Mal definiert
das ist hier keine Variable
das ist hier praktisch
in dieser Funktion definiert worden
und wenn wir dann
eine Funktion aufrufen
dann können wir da praktisch
mit diesem Keyword
genau den Wert
für diesen Parameter
praktisch definieren
da gibt es dann noch
eine dritte Sache
und das wäre praktisch
dieser Default-Parameter
sagen wir zum Beispiel
wir haben eine Funktion
kann ich hier das Beispiel herzeigen
sagen wir hier haben wir eine Funktion
die uns den Namen
ausschreiben will
aber
wir überlassen
praktisch
wir haben nicht immer
das Land zur Verfügung
und dann können wir einfach sagen
wenn wir das Land nicht zur Verfügung haben
dann soll einfach
das Default praktisch als
normaler Wert
ausspär verwendet werden
das heißt wenn wir hier diese Funktion aufrufen
aber Country nicht angeben
dann geht
die Funktion davon aus
du willst einfach diesen Standard-Wert
hier drin haben
ich kann natürlich
warte
kann mich hier nicht mehr zurück
cool
ja dann machen wir einfach das her
geben wir ein paar Beispiele durch
sagen wir wir haben jetzt wieder
diese gleiche Funktion hier definiert
dann was kann ich machen
ich kann machen
nur positional Argument
das heißt praktisch
max wird hier in first
reingeschrieben
Muster wird in die zweite reingeschrieben
wir haben kein drittes positional Argument
deshalb wird da hier
Standard-Wert verwendet
wir können natürlich diesen Standard-Wert
überschreiben
dann machen wir einfach hier ein drittes positional Argument
dann steht hier nicht mehr in Country
als Standard-Wert
aus hier drin sondern wird überschrieben mit Germany
das gilt aber nur für diesen Funktionsaufruf
also der wird dann nicht
für immer überschrieben
für diesen Funktionsaufruf
dann können wir das gleiche natürlich auch mit keyword machen
also da können wir dann keyword
keyword angeben
das Interessante bei keyword ist, die sind jetzt nicht positional
also die können wir irgendwie umdauschen
sagen wir, wir wollen
zuerst das Country definieren
dann ist das vollkommen möglich
das Wichtigste ist nur
positional Arguments
sind immer vor den keyword Arguments zu verwenden
also wenn ihr hier
zuerst ein keyword Argument verwendet
und dann ein positional Argument
dann wird euch bei von einer Fehler werfen
das kann man jetzt auch kurz zeigen
eben
gibt es mehrere Fehler
die da auftreten können
zum einen eben
diese Argumentreihenfolge
die eben falsch sein kann
das heißt zum Beispiel, dass wir positional
keyword
positional Arguments nach keyword
keyword Arguments haben
können dann auch einfacher
Tippfehler sein
bei der keyword
Zuweisung, das heißt
wenn
last
hier zum Beispiel, wenn wir hier das a vergessen
dann wird peifen
uns auch einen Fehler werfen, weil
lsd
praktisch nicht definiert ist
sondern nur last
dann natürlich, wenn man zu viele Argumente
rein schreibt
positional Argument nach keyword Argument
nochmal, ja
es kann natürlich auch sein
dass wir dann in der Funktion
zum Beispiel
sagen wir, wir haben ja eine Funktion
die uns was addieren will
und wir gehen davon aus
dass wir hier integer bekommen
aber wir schreiben hier dann
max und muster rein
diese Funktion
dann
5 plus first
zu machen
das wird dann natürlich nicht funktionieren
da gibt es nämlich keinen check
dafür, dass da praktisch
das direkt ein integer ist
es gibt da schon typing, aber
wie gesagt, das ist dann
eigentlich schon wieder advanced
genau gehen wir da ein paar Beispiele durch
sagen wir, wir haben wieder
unsere Funktion hier
hier zum Beispiel
haben wir
ein Argument vergessen
hier haben wir praktisch nur
ein positional Argument
max, das heißt
first wird richtig überschrieben
aber mustermann fehlt
oder
muster
das heißt
er wird uns einen Fehler werfen
und sagt, da fehlt ein Parameter
den haben wir da nicht angegeben
so haben wir das zum Beispiel ausprobiert
sagen wir zum Beispiel
ich habe hier
erste
Parameter
jetzt haben wir hier
einen Parameter definiert
aber rufen hier cool ohne Parameter
dann kommen wir hier diesen type error
natürlich
wenn wir den hier als default
also mit einem
Standardwert definieren
ist das kein Problem
wie ihr seht verwend ich denn gar nicht
den Parameter, das ist nämlich auch vollkommen
egal, also
ich kann hier Parameter in der Funktion definieren
die ich aber nie wirklich verwende
da gibt es keinen Fehler
genau
dann gibt es natürlich auch so logische Fehler
zum Beispiel
wenn ich die positional Arguments
vertausche
zum Beispiel hier
habe ich
das Country davor
definiert
dass hier ist ein logischer Fehler
das passiert im Beifen hinter nix
weil der weiß ja nicht
dass du am Anfang den first name willst
und dann den last name
sondern
der weiß nur braucht drei Parameter
oder praktisch zwei
und einen default Parameter
der nicht unbedingt angegeben werden muss
dann
gibt es natürlich das auch
dass wenn das keyword falsch geschrieben ist
da wird auch ein Fehler geworfen
weil fs hier ist nirgends definiert
also hier haben wir kein fs
hier haben wir kein fs
was mit fs machen
aber das gibt es nicht
deshalb bekommen wir da auch ein Fehler
und
zu guter Letzt nochmal
praktisch positional Arguments
müssen immer vor den keyword Arguments sein
gibt es da zu fragen
ok
dann gehen wir das mal an einem tollen Beispiel durch
davor wir haben hier drei Funktionen definiert
und dann hier wird runProgram
aufgerufen
was passiert
zuerst wird mal hier
zu dieser Stelle
im code gesprungen
da haben wir dann
eine Variable definiert
die praktischen Liste ist
und die übergeben wir dann
einer zweiten Funktion
die wir hier definiert haben
das heißt
hier haben wir dieses Elements
das sind so neue Parameter
und hier übergeben wir
diese Variable
das heißt Elements
ist praktisch das gleiche wie
Standard Elements
also da haben wir praktisch die gleichen Werte drin stehen
und dann wird hier das Print aufgerufen
und dann geben wir hier
ein zweiter Print
da haben wir noch eine zweite Funktion
die aufgerufen wird
das heißt wir müssen zuerst
in diese Funktion reingehen
und da haben wir
dieses Elements wieder
das ist dann wieder das gleiche Elements wie hier
das ist aber ein anderes Elements wie das hier
sehr kompliziert
und dann
der macht uns ein FormatString
ListLength ist
und dann bekommen wir die Liste
von dieser Elements
Argument
da wichtig haben wir dieses Return
das heißt
wir gehen hier
wir schreiben dann
diesen ReturnValue
hier rein
und da bekommen wir dann praktisch
das Aus
praktisch das erste Print hier
List of Elements
das hier
und dann das zweite Print
schaut sehr kompliziert aus
kann am Anfang
vielleicht ein bisschen verwirrend sein
aber da kommen eigentlich die schnell rein
was ist zum Beispiel
da will ich euch ein Beispiel zeigen
da
was wenn wir sowas haben
ich definiere mir 2 Funktionen
diese Funktion ruft
die zweite auf
und die zweite ruft die erste auf
das heißt wir haben ja hier
eigentlich so eine Abschleife
und dann rufen wir sie auf
und dann wird das
hier aufgerufen, aufgerufen, aufgerufen
aufgerufen, aufgerufen
bis sie irgendwann sagt
bei sie sagen ah, irgendwas stimmt da nicht
also es ist nicht so wie eine Endlöschleife
sondern hier erreichen wir dann
ich habe es kurz davor erwähnt
praktisch es gibt auch Funktionen
die sich selber aufrufen können
das ist eigentlich sehr ähnlich dazu
irgendwann erreichen wir
dieses Rekursionslimit
das heißt
nach dem hunderttausendmal
sagt bei sie nahe zu Schluss
hier stimmt irgendwas nicht
also wenn ich das auch nochmal
kurz so zeige
ich muss mich zuerst definieren
dann kann ich da drin nämlich
die Funktion
nochmal aufrufen
die läuft und läuft und läuft
und dann irgendwann kommt zu diesen
Rekursionsfehler
für was ist so
eine rekursive Funktion eigentlich
notwendig
schauen wir mal da zum Beispiel so was machen
hier müssen wir noch
praktisch wie eine Schleife
die ruft sich immer wieder selber auf
also eigentlich ziemlich
dasselbe wie eine Weilschleife ist
nur dass wir die
Funktion selber aufrufen
was passiert
wir gehen hier rein
in diese Schleife
arbeiten hier durch
0 plus 1 ist 1
1 ist kleiner als 5
das ist wahr, deshalb rufen wir hier nochmal
A auf
das ganze geht nochmal rein
aber diesmal haben wir hier 1 drin stehen
1 plus 1 ist
dann geht es weiter
bis hier 5 drin stehen haben
dann ist dieses if nicht mehr erfüllt
und dann
passiert nichts mehr
dann gehen wir wieder hier zurück